but when Napoleon Dynamite became such a
phenomenon were they sort of like
because when when when I hit success my
I took my grandparents to a convention
and there was a line wrapped around and
uh my grandfather goes who are all these
people in the line what's wrong with
them who are they here for I'm like I
think they're here to see me and he goes
what the hell is this what is wrong with
me this is this is crazy he couldn't it
was mind-blowing and to see the look on
his face of like well my grandson has
some kind of accomplishment here he did
something that people recognize and they
like him yeah they were blown away I
took him to Planet Hollywood for a
Premiere once and they I just seen the
look on the face on their faces made me
happier than I've ever been seeing how
happy they were for me made me happier
than I could ever be so did your parents
when did they know something's different
it was a it was a little bit of a um I
say a curve it took a little bit of time
because but which is interesting because
Napoleon almost
I seen a poem took a little bit of time
but in in the terms of
you know having it come out in June of
2004
but most people will tell you oh yeah
Napoleon was an overnight success right
even though it was it took its time but
it was like out of nowhere it felt like
it was an overnight success because it
came from nowhere right nobody was in it
that anybody knew right so yes it was
instant Fame but you know it still was
like
I did this movie my parents knew I was
shooting this movie
and they knew I was dabbling in the
acting and he was just like yeah well
that's what they did on their videos we
made videos and we directed them but we
would act in our act I'm doing finger
quotes right act in our videos but we
would be on camera because I loved
goofing around in front of the camera as
well so it wasn't a surprise and my
oldest brother in my old and my sister
as well like they did like high school
plays they were all especially my oldest
brother he was into drama he was into
the school plays so that was actually
everybody thought he was gonna go and be
the actor
um
so when I just started doing it it was
just kind of like they knew we wanted to
get into Hollywood somehow right and
into the movie making so it wasn't that
big a surprise with that but we do
Napoleon Napoleon's coming out and it
goes to Sundance and Sundance I tell
everybody that's really when my life
changed everything changed was was
Sundance because that was the first
validation right that was looking you
just feel what happened you went to a
screening for it it was the I you would
call it the premiere but it was that
Sundance it was the first screening
it was packed uh it was it was like one
of their biggest venues there
um as big if not bigger than yeah way
bigger than a normal was it the first
time you had seen the movie yeah I I'd
seen part I don't know if I saw the
whole movie but I saw a rough cut which
you know that early on in my career I
was like I cannot watch a rough cut
again of a movie I'm in yeah I know
because I was just like this is bad
they're like no no this sounds not done
the picture's not locked you know it's
hard to comprehend yeah so I um so I
just kind of put that out of memory and
waited for the first screening to really
you know were you nervous at the
screening I was not nervous you weren't
no Jared the director he was sitting
right you know I think right behind me
or next to me or whatever
he was nervous he was dry heaving
because this was his baby
he was dry heaving yeah he was like
nauseous yeah he was he was nervous he
was absolutely nervous and I was like
kind of thinking Jared what like what do
you get to lose we're not anybody's
right now like we've got nothing to lose
so if it's no good if people don't like
it and then you know it's embarrassing
for a small amount of people in my life
right but I also knew we did the short I
believed strongly in the product I was
like dude I think if it's not great it's
not going to be terrible because they
just don't get it you know whatever
but we watched it for the first screen
it was just it was one of the most
memorable moments of my life I mean
people what was it like what was it like
people coming up for you and shot the
first shot of this film you know he's
standing there I'm standing there with
the Trapper Keeper waiting for the bus
and that's when people just like they
started laughing immediately kind of
like yeah kind of chuckling and then
because people in an audience especially
at Sundance and they know they're with
the filmmakers
people want to be the first to discover
something so they're willing they're
going out on a limb to take a chance
right they're willing to CH like be the
first people who are like no this is
awesome and then if it doesn't do well
then they might you know retract that
statement later but they want to be the
ones to say no I was the first one to
see it if it in case it does you know
find success